we've been slaying looting and clicking
through Diablo's procedurally generated
dungeons for over 25 years the original
Diablo birthed the action RPG genre and
it continued to hone that formula to
become an absolutely giant franchise to
celebrate the launch of Diablo 4 here's
a look back at the history of Diablo
the 1994 pitch for Diablo is really
interesting to go back and read today
the document presented a game that's
pretty similar to what we know of as
Diablo now from the beginning it was
always built with replayability in mind
with an emphasis on exploration and
experimenting with the game's different
classes but there were key differences
namely that Diablo was originally
planned to be a turn-based game with
permadeath and that it would be expanded
by adding items and quests through
expansion packs inspired by Magic the
Gathering booster packs this project was
the baby of developer David Breivik and
the team at Condor but it wasn't in
active development instead they were
working on Justice League task force for
Sega
and at the CES trade show in 1994 they
met the team from Silicon and synapse
who were also working on Justice League
task force but this time for Nintendo
neither developer knew about the other
game but they got to talking anyway and
the silicon and synapse devs revealed
that they were itching to make their own
Fantasy PC games they all agreed to keep
in touch and after silicon and synapse
shipped a small game called Warcraft
what
and changed their name to Blizzard
reps from the team came to visit Condor
to check out Diablo blizzard offered
Condor 300 000 to make Diablo but it
quickly became apparent that it wouldn't
be enough Condor landed a one million
dollar side gig to make a football title
for the 3DO M2 console and even though
the M2 Never released 3DO offered to buy
the small Studio this kicked off a
bidding war between 3DO and blizzard
with Condor eventually picking team
blizzard because their cultures aligned
more in 1996 Condor became blizzard
North and development on Diablo was full
steam ahead but blizzard South had some
ideas about the game and urged North to
make the game Real Time instead of
turn-based brevik who was lead
programmer claimed that this would take
a lot of work and even got another
Milestone payment from blizzard for the
trouble turns out it was actually pretty
easy to do and brevik ended up doing it
in an afternoon Diablo
enter if you dare Diablo is often
credited with being the first action RPG
and it launched alongside Battle.net
Blizzard's proprietary gaming platform
that allows players to control their
blizzard games connect with others and
play together Diablo's gameplay Loop of
exploring procedurally generated
dungeons fighting monsters and
collecting loot proved to be an
irresistible combination its three
character classes Warrior Rogue and
sorcerer added even more variety and the
game could even be played online
admittedly rampant cheating was a huge
issue but when the game launched it was
a huge critical and Commercial hit on
9.6 out of 10 reviews stated that if you
like PC games you should go out right
now and experience what is likely to be
the Clone maker for the next two years
Diablo is often cited as being one of
the best PC games ever made and a
version was made for the PS1 by Climax
and published by EA in 1998. hot on the
heels of the massive success of Diablo
the executs at Blizzard's parent company
Davidson and Associates were pushing for
more content and despite blizzard
North's objections another team owned by
the conglomerate was given the task of
making an expansion and only six weeks
in which to do it after assurance that
blizzard North could executive produce
the pack representatives from the
original team met with synergistic
software to discuss the expansion and
provide some guidance as well as house
rules blizzard North only allowed
synergistic software to include one new
character class and told them outright
that they couldn't add to Diablo's
multiplayer because it would require a
complete rebalancing of the online
portion of the game luckily for the team
at synergenistic software their deadline
was extended to four months and the
expansion Hellfire launched in 1997. it
added a new storyline items and
improvements to the game's interface
true to their word they only added one
new character class the monk however
there were two unfinished classes left
in the game that could be accessed
pretty easily by tweaking the
commands.txt file The Bard and the
Barbarian Diablo 2 was released in 2000
and it was immediately clear that the
sequel was bigger and more complex than
the original exploration was no longer
relegated to its dungeons Diablo 2 had
an Overworld with more varied
environments improvements were made to
its storytelling crucially quests were
no longer random and instead linked
together to tell a more cohesive tale
across its four acts at launch there
were five character classes instead of
three Amazon Necromancer Barbarian
sorceress and Paladin and three
difficulty levels there's also a
hardcore mode that introduces permadeath
for your character Diablo 2's quirkiest
addition to the franchise is undoubtedly
a hidden cow level by transmuting
specific items a portal would appear
that would take players to the secret
cow level which was filled with cows led
by the cow king the cow level goes back
as early as the original Diablo when an
online hoax LED people to believe that
it existed in the original game
synogynistic software through a
reference to it in the Hellfire
expansion access once again by tweaking
the command.txt file Diablo 2 was
designed with much more emphasis on
Cooperative multiplayer working to fix
the cheating issues that plagued the
original game by introducing open and
closed Realms although the cheating
issues weren't solved entirely there was
definitely some improvement there's also
a ladder system for multiplayer where
characters would be reset at the end of
a season to allow players to play on
equal footing Diablo 2 flew off the
shelves when it launched in 2000 and
despite being criticized for its dated
Graphics it also reviewed pretty well a
remake Diablo 2 resurrected was released
in 2021 that updated the game's Graphics
but if you yearn for that 2000s
aesthetic you could swap to the old
style with the push of a button a year
after Diablo 2's launch and expansion
was released this time developed by the
original team at blizzard North on top
of new items and gameplay mechanics like
more control over hilings it added a
Fifth Act to the game's story and a new
demonic boss to battle ball Lord Of
Destruction also added two new character
classes the Druid and the Assassin we
gave it an 8.2 with reviewer Greg
cassavin saying that the expansion
offers plenty of new features enough to
make you spend at least as much time
with the expansion as you have with the
original game
you cannot judge me
I am Justice itself we were meant for
more than this to protect the innocent
after the enormous success of Diablo 2
the team at blizzard North began work on
Diablo 3. speaking to IGN blizzard North
co-founder Eric Schaefer revealed that
it was a vastly different game it was a
true MMO with a stronger faction and PVP
Focus but it was still in early
development and really I don't remember
much about it after some conflict with
Blizzard's then owner vivendi many key
Talent from blizzard North including
David Breivik and the other co-founders
departed from the studio blizzard North
Diablo 3 was canceled and the studio
closed down in 2005. blizzard South in
Irvine took the lead with Fallout
co-creator Leonard boyarsky acting as
the game's lead World designer and
Company of Heroes J Wilson as game
director Flash Forward to 2008 and at
the blizzard worldwide Invitational in
Paris blizzard revealed Diablo 3 to the
world
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
has you play as the Nephilim offspring
of a demon and Angel investigating a
star that's Fallen onto the cathedral
near Tristram yes the very same
Cathedral that once concealed Diablo's
Soul Stone in the original game
launching with five classes with an
additional two coming in later
expansions Diablo 3 was widely praised
upon release for refining the
franchise's compelling gameplay loop our
reviewer Carolyn Pettit wrote the
controls are responsive and pleasurable
the diversity of character classes and
skill customization options is
impressive and the constant stream of
gold and treasure you earn is
irresistible Diablo has the recipe for
crafting a habit-forming loot-driven
action RPG down to a science and in
Diablo 3 the results of that recipe are
more exciting and more addictive than
they've ever been while the core
gameplay was solid Diablo 3's launch was
nothing short of disastrous the game
requires players to be connected to the
internet at times even when playing
alone at launch when hundreds of
thousands of players were eager to head
back to Sanctuary they were presented
with the most horrifying thing
imaginable while the development team
worked tirelessly to implement a fix to
the servers players review bombed the
game on Metacritic and lambasted the
team on the official Blizzard forums
even after the server issues were sorted
it wouldn't be the end of Diablo 3's
woes thanks to the implementation of its
controversial Auction House an online
storefront where players could exchange
in-game gold or real world money for
items Blizzard's reasoning for including
the auction house was to legitimize
third-party trading to prevent players
from being scammed by third-party sites
unfortunately it was met with a lot of
criticism because of course blizzard
were taking a cut players accused the
game of having pay-to-win aspects and
the auction house was removed a couple
of years later for now we want you to
know that both the real money auction
house and the gold auction house will be
shut down on March 18th
2014. it actually took so long to be
taken offline because blizzard were
concerned that they would open the
company up to legal action because the
auction house was listed as a feature on
the back of the box despite some
missteps Diablo 3 would be an enormous
success and to celebrate its 10th
anniversary blizzard revealed that the
game had over 65 million players since
launch it came to PlayStation 3 and Xbox
360 in 2013 PS4 and Xbox One the
following year and even to the Nintendo
switch in 2018 Diablo 3's console ports
would be widely praised for managing to
effectively translate the game's PC
controls to controller
foreign
first expansion Reaper of Souls was
released in 2014 on top of adding new
story content and quality of life
updates the expansion also added a
number of gameplay features including
Seasons new dungeons called Nephilim
Rifts the defensive Crusader class and
race the level cap from 60 to 70. it
also added adventure mode where players
could complete bounties for rewards in
every region off the map Reaper of Souls
reviewed well and sold almost 3 million
copies in its first week
pack released for Diablo 3 in 2017 rise
of the necromancer's biggest feature was
the introduction of the you guessed it
Necromancer class and not much else its
release coincided with a free patch that
introduced challenge Rifts and new
bounties to the game but still people
were pretty cheesed off that they had to
Shell out 15 for a character class with
no new story content to go along with it
[Music]
BlizzCon
we love Diablo
during the BlizzCon 2018 opening
ceremony Wyatt Chang took to the main
stage to talk about the future of Diablo
fans eagerly anticipating a new Mainline
entry were surprised to hear that the
next game would actually be a
free-to-play mobile and PC title called
Diablo Immortal hey uh just was
wondering is this uh an out of season
April Fool's joke
uh to Blizzard's credit they had tried
to preempt the announcement by telling
people not to raise their hopes too much
but when has that ever stopped the
internet from overreacting to things
co-developed with netease a Chinese
company that published a number of
Blizzard games in China including Diablo
3 Diablo Immortal was poised as a
full-fledged action RPG set between
Diablo 2 and 3. our reviewer Alessandro
Barbosa praised the game's touch
controls how it looked and how it
evolved the Diablo formula but
criticized the late to end game content
where progression would slow
significantly necessitating paying for
the best in-game items using real world
money one such player YouTuber JT is all
business spent a hundred thousand
dollars on in-game items but found out
very quickly that it's Lonely at the Top
he tried to find a PVP match between 48
and 72 hours and couldn't find anyone to
play blizzard eventually issued a fix
despite criticism of its micro
transactions Diablo Immortal earned a
hundred million dollars in its first
eight weeks in November 2022 Activision
Blizzard ended its long-term partnership
with netease suspending game services in
mainland China and netease executive
even publicly wrote on his LinkedIn that
the relationship broke down due to a
jerk at Activision Blizzard blizzard
games such as World of Warcraft and
OverWatch are no longer able to be
purchased in the country but Diablo
Immortal which was covered by a separate
agreement is still available which
brings us to Diablo 4.
successful reveal at BlizzCon 2018
blizzard pulled out all the stops at
2019's show offering the first look at
the brand new entry in the series with a
distinctly dark and gory trailer
featuring The Game's big bad Lily
said 30 years after Reaper of Souls the
demon Lewis has been summoned to
sanctuary and in classic Diablo Fair
it's your job to take her out the
biggest changes to Diablo 4 include its
open world and after it didn't
meaningfully materialize in Diablo 3 PVP
its Overworld can be freely explored and
after completing the story is even
shared with other players online meaning
that you might see others running around
and completing public events like boss
fights also after completing a certain
amount of the game you get access to a
mount which makes traversing around much
easier our reviewer Alessandro Barbosa
gave it an 8 out of 10 saying Diablo 4
at this time cannot Escape comparison to
the past of the franchise it belongs to
but it's thankfully a game that has been
crafted with a strong awareness of what
made each one either revered or reviled
it represents a measured approach to
combining the many elements from
previous entries that worked into a
system that feels like the new standard
Bearer for Action role-playing we have
plenty more on Diablo 4 right here on
Gamespot so make sure you tune in to
check it all out thank you so much for
watching I'm on Twitter at Lucy James
games and I'll see you next time for
more history of